in den wolken der venus könnte sich
verstecken außerirdisches leben in
gleich zwei aktuellen studien stellen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
diese neue hypothese vor in der höheren
atmosphäre der venus deutet ammoniak gas
auf potenzielles leben in lebensformen
die säuren neutralisieren gibt es also
tatsächlich leben auf der venus klicks
auf youtube gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
unser nachbar planet die venus ist eine
echte höllen landschaft laut der
us-raumfahrtbehörde nasa handelt es sich
um eine inferno ähnliche welt und
dennoch sind einige wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler felsenfest davon
überzeugt dass wir genau dort fündig
werden könnten außerirdisches leben
könnte sich hier versteckt halten erst
vor einiger zeit hatten fachleute in der
atmosphäre der venus hinweise auf
mögliche biologische aktivität gefunden
das interesse an der venus ist
ungebrochen und die nasa plant gleich
zwei forschungsmission zu unserem
nachbarplaneten im rahmen des discovery
programms hat die us-behörde die mission
da vinci plus und veritas ausgewählt die
raumsonden sollen bereits in wenigen
jahren
2028 bis 2030 zur venus starten und das
könnte spannend werden denn einige
forschen sie sind wirklich felsenfest
davon überzeugt dass auf unserem
nachbarplaneten leben existiert so zum
beispiel die beiden forschern vom
renommierten massachusetts institute of
technology mit sarah sieger und william
den sie forschen unermüdlich zum thema
und haben nun weiter reden weiß er
darauf gefunden die organisches leben in
den wolken der venus plausibel
erscheinen lassen welche indizien
sprechen also dafür und ist es wirklich
möglich dass unser nachbarplanet
außerirdisches leben beherbergt die
spannenden antworten auf all diese
fragen gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum
science den future im herbst 2020 hatte
das astronomie team den sensationsfund
gemeldet mit hilfe von radioteleskopen
in chile und dabei wollen die fachleute
in der venus atmosphäre
einen super spektakulären fund gemacht
haben denn dort in der dichten
wolkendecke der venus soll es ihnen
gelungen sein mono verfahren
nachzuweisen wie sie damals im
fachmagazin nature s sony
veröffentlichen dabei handelt es sich um
eine hochgiftige verbindung aus
wasserstoff im fonds vor das
spektakuläre daran auch nicht
biologischem wege kann dieses molekül in
der natur wohl nicht entstehen auf der
erde sind dafür nur zwei quellen bekannt
zum einen mikroben die ganz ohne
sauerstoff auskommen und zum anderen
chemie laboratorien im klartext heißt
das also mono fonds fahren als ein
möglicher kandidat für hinweise auf
wasser und schluss leben doch ist dieser
angebliche sensationsfund gar keine
wirkliche entdeckung die studie stieß
bereits damals jedenfalls auf großen
widerspruch und skepsis in der fachwelt
kein wunder denn auf den ersten blick
scheint die - alles andere als lebens
tauglich auf der oberfläche unseres
nachbarplaneten herrscht eine
durchschnittstemperatur von rund also
durchschnittstemperatur von rund 460
grad celsius das wäre heiß genug um leid
zu schmelzen die atmosphäre des planeten
besteht zum größten teil aus
kohlendioxid und ist zudem extrem dicht
so herrscht auf der venus eindruck der
auf der erde rund 900 meter unter wasser
entspricht doch ganz anders wohl die
frühe vergangenheit dieses planeten der
vor langer zeit durchaus bewohnbar
gewesen sein könnte bedeckt mit ozean
und somit mit einer deutlich kühleren
oberfläche als heute an kann es also auf
dem leben eines sehr gut vorstellbar
wären die venus könnte also bei der
suche nach außerirdischem leben eine
bedeutende rolle spielen als man bislang
angenommen hatte denn falls die venus
mit großen lebensfreundlichen ozean
vielleicht sogar drei milliarden lang
tatsächlich wie die erde aus gesehen hat
ist auch eine sache ganz klar die
evolution hatte hier genug zeit in
aktion zu treten genügend zeit also für
die entstehung von leben doch der
spektakuläre fund des mono fonds fand's
in den wolken der venus blieb weiter
umstritten anfang 2021 dagegen wurden
sogar eine studie veröffentlicht in der
andere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die spektren untersucht
hatten und keine spuren des moleküls
ausfindig machen konnten doch dann
plötzlich gab es eine unerwartete
unterstützung und die kontroverse ein
potenzielles leben auf der venus wurde
einfach denn ein nasa forschungsteam hat
sie sich 40 jahre alte daten noch einmal
genauer angeschaut 1978 war eine nasa
sonde durch die atmosphäre der venus
geflogen hatte dabei viele spannende
daten sammeln können auch spuren des
mono fonds fans waren damals dabei
schrieb das forschungsteam nach einer
ausgiebigen analyse der längsten daten
und nicht nur das die nasa fachleute
konnten in den alten daten weitere
spannende indizien für die existenz von
leben feststellen die rede ist unter
anderem von nitrat schwefelwasserstoff
kohlenmonoxid ammoniak getan und nitrit
komponenten die unter anderem für den
sogenannten stickstoffkreislauf
bedeutsam sind findet in der venus
atmosphäre also möglicherweise sogar
etwas wie photosynthese stadt dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam wenn wir die
potenzielle bewohnbarkeit der venus
folgen betrachten zeigen unsere arbeiten
eine mögliche signatur des an er oben
phosphor stoffwechsel sowie wichtige
chemische beiträge zur an optionen
photosynthese und zum terrestrischen
stickstoffkreislauf feststeht was also
tatsächlich für den mono phosphatgehalt
in der venus atmosphäre sorgt kann mit
letzter sicherheit nur durch eine
mission zur venus herausgefunden werden
doch die beiden venus fachleute sarah
sieger und william beier vom lassen
nicht locker und setzten ihre forschung
zur venus atmosphäre ford in gleich zwei
aktuellen studien offenbaren sie nun
weitere hinweise die auf organisches
leben in den venus wolken schließen
lassen konkret haben die forschenden und
ihr forschungsteam ein modell der venus
atmosphäre erstellt mit dessen hilfe
verschiedene chemische prozesse
simuliert werden können ihre ausgangs
theorie stützt sich auf eine studie was
den siebzigerjahren fachleute wollen
hier in der atmosphäre des nachbar
planeten das gas ammoniak nachgewiesen
haben ein wirklich spektakulärer fund
denn in den gemessenen mengen kann er
unmöglich mit den uns bekannten
chemischen prozessen auf der venus
erklärt werden genau deswegen ist die
existenz von ammoniak auf der venus auch
bis heute umstritten doch die
astrophysikerin sarah sieger und ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen setzen genau
hier an dazu sagt sarah sieger jedes
gras das in den kontext der venus umwelt
gehört wird automatisch interessant wenn
es darum geht nach hinweisen für leben
auf der venus zu tun und was könnte die
existenz von ammoniak gas bedeuten das
forschungsteam geht davon aus dass
einfache lebensformen ihre extrem sauren
umgebung lebens von bücher machen und
zwar über die bildung von ammoniak
dieser prozess ist für bestimmte
einfache lebensformen auf der erde
bekannt und die simulation der
physikerinnen und physiker legen nahe
dass genau das auch in der venus
atmosphäre der fall sein könnte doch
woher kommt das ammoniak es
möglicherweise sogar von lebewesen die
die venus besiedelt eine vorstellung die
laut der fachleute plausibler erscheint
als das das ammoniak durch vulkanische
eruptionen blitze oder
meteoriteneinschläge erzeugt und
freigesetzt wird laut den fachleuten
könnte sich das leben auf der venus
seine eigene umwelt erschaffen beispiele
dafür gibt es sogar im menschlichen
körper magen bakterien neutralisieren
ebenfalls ihre sehr saubere umgebung und
machen sie es dadurch für sie bewohnbar
das fazit des forschungsteams so gut wie
kein unbekanntes leben könnte in der
extrem sauren atmosphäre der venus
überleben aber der punkt ist dass es
dort vielleicht leben gibt dass seine
umgebung so verändert dass citroen
wohnbau wird und nicht nur dass diese
hypothese würde zudem sogar noch
erklären warum in den wolken unseres
nachbarplaneten auch molekularer
sauerstoff sowie wasser und
schwefeldioxid in nicht
nachvollziehbaren verteilungen vorkommen
ammoniak würde also innerhalb der venus
folgten in den schwefelsäure tropfen
gelöst und würde diese neutralisieren so
würde eine chemische reaktion folgen die
auch schwefeldioxid im umfeld der
tropfen zur folge hätte heißt also die
anwesenheit von ammoniak könnte somit
die meisten chemischen anomalien der
venus wolken erklären das fazit von
sarah sieger ist klar auf der venus gibt
es noch einige anomalien die wir nicht
verstehen die aber faszinierende
möglichkeiten aufzeigen und raum für
mögliches leben
ihre spektakuläre hypothese könnte sogar
vor ort überprüft werden und zwar mit
der hilfe charakteristische chemische
signaturen die zukünftige missionen
detektieren können der plan des
forschungsteams privat finanzierte
mission die sich intensiv mit der suche
nach leben auf der venus beschäftigen
leben auf der venus wissenschaft findet
für sensationsfunde nur eine erklärung
hier geht es zu dem sensationsfund von
mofas fahren auf der venus also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren um
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran